sister you said the Quran says that a
person was born as a Muslim and he
changes his religion he put to death
sister I don't know if any verse in the
Quran he took he raided a Jewish tribe
the king of Peace he trying to make
peace in the community he didn't come if
he was really coming and he wanted to
get rid of the Jews he had the power and
the will to do that this is the shahada
she came out Muhammad said anybody who
changes his religion kill
him
he's not aware of this story being
fabricated he didn't Stone the lady who
committed adultery he lives without sins
let him cast a first stone that that was
not in the original I think there should
be an investigation to find his family
to find his father I second that now a
devout Christian convert warning the
world Islam is out to destroy
[Music]
you that's how you recite the Quran I
know the Quran inside out and I'll tell
you what I'm really excited the dean
Center is becoming a reality allahar
pulling the resources together making
this dream a reality a mega dawa Center
in the United States allahar this is the
future and it's happening we've got the
location but now we got to get the work
going we got to build the mjid we got to
build the da Center we need you to
donate now not for me not for Eddie but
for that mjid for that house of Allah
that Allah would be worshiped in we need
to build that da Center where people
people can come from across the world
and come and get trained in how to give
da and non-muslims can come and learn
about Islam we got to get this done
everybody donate let's do this together
it's happening
allahar asalam alaikum greetings and
peace welcome to the Sham Med your host
hit that notification Bell subscribe if
you haven't already so you don't miss
exciting programs like this with my
exciting next guest you guys all
probably by now most of you if you
haven't already have heard about the
conversation of the year that happened
where we got on a platform where we were
talking unfortunately it was with career
islamophobes and they had a lot to say
they did the machine gun method so now
to address some of these things that
some people still might have some
questions about I have an Imam YF
susui he has memorized the entire Quran
it's one of the Miracles of the Quran
that is memorized by millions living
today from the past present and will
continue memorizing in the future and
has also a bachelor's degree in Islamic
Sciences amongst other
specialities and this is one of them so
we're going to go ahead and address many
of these we're going to dissect it go
look at the round table religious
discussion and we're going to go ahead
and break some of these things down
don't go
anywhere
let me introduce you to my
face we have one God name Allah
Allah and his final Messengers muhamad
peace be upon him this is our religion
Islam Islam this is
the love you you're doing when I was
ready to talk about it I would only talk
to you I was explaining
[Music]
forl how you doing my brother alham it's
very good to be back on your show after
a few months alh yourself alhamdulillah
nice to have you back here with us you
got a chance to uh see this uh Round
Table discussion yes yes very uh
informational very uh entertaining and
educational I should say um and a lot a
lot to take away from from that and uh
yeah yeah uh Daniel and uh Jake did a
really great job alhamdulillah yes we
were down there together and there's a
lot to un package you saw this and you
um there was some things that now you
know what are your thoughts at the end
of the day like overall overall with the
discussion how it went I would I would
have liked to have seen people you know
who aren't in in it for the money a
career uh as we call them islamophobes
haters people who at the end of the day
they're not going to really shift their
position you know it's like if someone's
praying wrong or someone is like what I
mean by is if there's a a there's
something that you're doing wrong in
Islam right and someone comes to you and
says you know you're not actually
supposed to do it like this and the
person is never going to change that's
how these person you know you you bring
them col scholarly consensus the right
way to interpret the Quran the right way
to go ahead and you know you bring them
all the scholar refence they're just
like no they're just going to keep
repeating the same thing because they've
been there's many situations where
they've been explaining no it's like
it's supposed to be like this uh just
like I you know this the the um the
verse of the sword um where Jesus talks
about I have not been sent uh to bring
spread peace but a sword but when a
Christian explains it to you that's you
know how it's actually supposed to be in
context we don't insist no no it's means
like this you know what I mean so uh
what are your thoughts that on that
where do I start okay um first I would
like to say that the likes of Robert
Spencer uh David wood and this uh this
other individual with them uh Rashid
hamami um there are many out there in in
in the non-muslim world especially in
the west uh UK non-muslim countries UK
Australia uh America there are many
people who are out there provocators as
you said last time uh people who are
spewing Venom
out there to very good well-intentioned
people who are really seeking the truth
they don't have any an animosity towards
Muslims they don't have any kind of
hostility however after listening to
some of the Venom that's being spewed by
this person and his ilk uh you really
you're really not left with an option
one one example that I think is is vivid
to bring up here is that you'll have
many who will say oh I was this devout
Muslim I was raised just very similar to
the story of Rashid hamami where he will
say I was raised in a very strict family
we were reading Quran we were studying
this we were up all night in other words
hey I'm coming with a lot of credibility
under my belt one that comes to mind is
Sam Solomon uh I've done a video re
rebutting him years ago this man comes
to a stage he comes to rule America rule
Minnesota to to to people who really
don't know much about Muslims right and
he tells them something as simple as
reading Surah zulul first off
it's and then he goes on to
say so he starts with the the name of
the chapter and then he says the chapter
wrong that's like me and this person
basically is telling his audience that
he taught Islam for 15 DEC for 15 years
in other words this is not an average
Muslim but come to find out he has his
ABCs of Islam completely screwed up he
cannot pronounce the Quran correctly but
you have knowing nothing about Islam
you're not going to know what's false
you're not going to know what's true you
have nothing to counter that with so
you're just going to assume that this
person is looking out for our best
interest but these people are only and
simply driven and motivated by the
monetary sum that comes out of this it's
not about being good-hearted looking out
for the well-being of others it's simply
based in money this is all a lot of
these people are after and you you
mentioned this Sam individual you also
have this W shabat you know heard of him
yeah what another clown yeah he was he
was a supposed uh guy who was out there
former Muslim he accepted uh he became a
Christian and he's on the the
islamophobia circuit right and he's out
there he was discredited uh they did a
report CNN they went back and they' saw
that he's a liar once a jew-hating bomb
thrwing terrorist now a devout Christian
convert warning the world Islam is out
to destroy
you
[Music]
that's how you recite the Quran I know
the Quran inside out his message before
a largely positive crowd of cops and
emergency responders at this South
Dakota Homeland Security conference
trust no muslim especially those who
organize know your
enemy know your
enemy all islamist organizations in
America should be the number one one
enemy all of them the islamist
organization Islamic societ of North
America should be focused on you got
that on camera yes please he is being
paid
$5,000 plus expenses to speak here with
your tax dollars being a terrorism
expert has become a cottage industry
since 9/11 the Department of Homeland
Security has spent nearly $40 million on
counterterrorism training just since
2006 an ex terrorist it's wall shabbats
claimed def Fame a terrorist a PLO
member who bombed a branch of an Israeli
Bank in Bethlehem Square throwing a
firebomb on the bank's roof the problem
with the story with a lot of shoot's
stories there's no evidence for them and
despite CNN's many requests neither
shoot nor his business partner have
provided us with any bombings in
Bethlehem Square you specifically said
you threw the bank was in in in the
Bethlehem Square through explosives yes
I did on top of that bank yes I did no
record CNN's Jerusalem Bureau went to
Great Lengths trying to verify shoot's
story finding the general location where
the branch of Bank Lumi once stood but
not finding anyone who could remember a
bombing we contacted the bank
headquarters in Tel Aviv asking
officials to search records no records
found and Israeli police found no record
anyone ever threw a bomb at the branch
of the bank why would the bank not have
a record why would the the Israeli
police not have a record why would the
Israeli police not have a record I don't
know I mean I don't know where you check
what dates all these things there's
another part of his story that doesn't
check out shat says he was arrested and
spent two weeks in an Israeli prison
there's no record of you being in prison
I think there'd be at least an arrest
record they held you for two weeks would
the United States know you that you were
in prison if you were citizen how about
me and you go to the musia prison and
attract the records the records are
there okay would you be willing to do so
we did and the Israeli Detention Center
could find no record of detaining anyone
with the name W shabat he's just a liar
he's just this is big business this is
money for him there's a lot of money
there's a lot of money to be made and
and let me just make for the r
Christians are seeing this though it's
smart I mean you can you know good
Americans out there who just you know
they're um taken away you know by much
of this propaganda and the fear machine
the Hate Machine but they're I think
they're starting to wake up slowly to
these uh profitter of the hate and as as
you said there are a lot of good
well-intentioned people out there but
unfortunately they're getting their news
from the wrong Avenues and unfortunately
this is what we have displayed in front
of them our our people like this what
else before we get into is what else uh
do you want to comment before because we
got quite a few here we're going to go
through the PD pbd podcast Patrick
McDavid podcast we're going to break
down
uh some of these things that they had
spoken about there was a lot of things
and um so some things uh and it's very
difficult you know at that time Daniel
and them they're getting all these
things so you can't address every single
thing right at the moment and that's
there that's what they their tactic was
just to throw that machine gun method
just throw a bunch of stuff out there Y
and go ahead and see like how you going
to handle it and in a short this short
amount of time it's definitely a scare
tactic for sure yeah it's a their tactic
and I think they're appealing to
people's emotions they're they're
dealing with people who are quite
frankly not I don't want to say naive
but they're ignorant of what Islam is
and what Islam isn't and I think often
times people's minds are changed when
they end up meeting Muslims firsthand oh
I didn't know you guys were like this
you guys are normal people you send your
kids to school too you guys go to Parks
you pay your taxes too right so they
don't realize this until they end up
having a Muslim neighbor or a Muslim
friend colleague or someone that they
work with right one takeaway that I
think that's very very very profound
that I find personally is looking at the
reaction from Patrick when he's speaking
and dealing with someone such as Daniel
hu right is that Muslims I think this
message is for us Muslims is that we
have to come to terms with the obvious
fact and the obvious reality that Islam
is unique Islam is different than every
other religion out there I think what
Muslims especially who are part of these
big organizations what they're what
they're priding themselves on is
unfortunately trying to show the Western
World how hey we're we're all we're no
different we're just like you guys the
problem with this method though is that
when your product looks like every other
product out on the market what makes you
stand out what's going to make that
person walking down the aisle and say
well what is this if your product looks
like every other product on the shelf
and it doesn't look different it doesn't
stand out where in the world is the
incentive for someone to stop do the
research and say I really want to know
more about this because some of us are
completely bent on the idea of hey we're
no different than you guys we I think
it's about time right I think the time
is now for us Muslims to stand up tall
and proud and to say no we're not like
you guys now this is not a message of
hostility we can still have Community
cohesion we can still have we can still
coexist one does not negate the other I
think a lot of people and again this
stems from a deep self- inferiority
complex is that some of us Muslims are
truly afraid just to express that we
don't do this in Islam there's no such
thing in Islam what we're doing is we
want to take every non-muslim concept
every cultural concept that's out there
and we want to appeal to a verse from
the Quran a Hadith from the Sunnah or a
story of the sahab and say ha see we
have a Muslim way of doing it so
sometimes we want to just islamy every
concept we have to come to the reality
and to the ter with the obvious fact
that some things cannot be
some more I just my mind started
thinking uh when you said that I mean
you can start from the basic things like
going to the bathroom right no we're not
like that like you in a sense that we
prefer water over toilet paper but we
can do both right washing so the minute
from the smallest things we have
Direction in life Purity in Islam how
it's so so important so another thing is
uh we're not like you we don't have to
go to the party and drink
alcohol um we don't have to intermingle
that's it's okay there's no such thing
we have set set boundaries uh another
thing is uh we don't have girlfriends we
marry yeah there's no such thing as an
Islamic boyfriend or an Islamic
girlfriend uh in worship we don't
worship creation we worship the one
Creator right alone so these are the
things but people respect that so much
and people actually when they look into
Islam they're like I want some of that
because it's the the complete wholesome
way of life it's beautiful but again I I
think the question the million-dollar
question is this what's the incentive if
I'm sitting here trying to show you that
hey I'm a carbon copy of you where is
the incentive for that person now to be
on your side if you're just telling them
hey you and I are just identical we're
alike we're twins where is the incentive
for that person out to make that leap
from that side of the fence onto this
side of the fence uniqu of itself it has
Apple product is an Apple product and
that's why people like apple right
because it has so you're saying like
that Islam is unique in its own special
very and we have to be proud of that we
have to stop trying to convince others
that uh no we have a Muslim way of doing
it sometimes there's no there's no
muslim way of doing it it's not Islamic
at all gotcha all right so we uh should
we get into it are you ready okay let's
go ahead and start probably the main
thing is the sanctification of violence
and the idea that God will bless and
even calls upon the Believers to commit
acts of violence under certain
circumstances like rashed here is an
ex-muslim and so under Islamic law as
it's traditionally and classically
formulated he would be put to death
Muhammad said anybody who changes his
religion kill him this is how they they
pretty much started off uh Patrick asked
him so what do you got against Islam and
he went specifically for what we call
the penino code and if I'm not mistaken
the penino code makes up uh two 3% of uh
or give the whole message of Islam yes
so what are your thoughts now yeah it
it's funny but but that's not they did
they did a brilliant job Daniel Jake
they took it back to you know them
actually following liberal secular
secularism not Christianity because the
same thing you know you have many of the
injunctions they're there in your in the
Bible yeah uh one there there's a lot to
unpack when it comes to this first it's
not out of thin air it's not
spontaneously done in other words for
someone like Robert Spencer to come with
the first thing to bring out and to
mention the concept of violence in Islam
uh or the concept or the idea or had of
the the apostasy law it's it's not out
of thin a and it's not done
spontaneously that is that is
intentional and that is again he's
playing on the emotions of the the the
well-intentioned uh viewer first off
when we talk about that he gives the
impression that it is our job as Muslims
that if we hear about someone leaving
Islam that it is our duty to meet up and
go looking for this person that is not
our job so misconception number one is
that we as Muslims there's no such thing
as being a vigilante in especially in
this case meaning that if someone leaves
Islam it's not your job it's not my job
this is the job of the Muslim government
there's a tribunal there's a court
there's a judge and again the as the
prophet he
says is to word off these H these
directives or these punishments with any
kind of misconception or or
misunderstanding is you word it off that
that's just how clear Islam makes it uh
I think Point number two that's worth
mentioning is that there's a lot of
nuance when it comes to the idea of
apostasy it's not just any random person
right the will ask that person why are
you leaving some people might actually
admit it's simply for monetary reasons
it's simply for the and I know this
might you know cause people to chuckle
some people leave Islam because they
want to come to the US they want a green
card they're looking for a better life
it's not necessarily I'm leaving Islam
because I want to or some people might
genuinely leave Islam because they don't
agree with it they they disagree with it
so I'm not here to negate that sector
they do exist out there right uh Point
number three when we talk about the
Nuance the Hadith is
there that is a it's a sound Hadith
however there are other that Define this
differently in I can clarify that
quickly
asks he
says the people of Bak the six indiv ual
of what happened to
them
says they left Islam and they joined the
disbelievers right
so and then he
says the only thing that ought to be
done to them is for them to be killed
so
said says that if they came back to me
peacefully right would be very very
beloved to me so an was intrigued by
that because it wasn't it wasn't a
response he was expecting from from Omar
so
says oh if these six came back to you
peacefully right what would you do with
them he
says he says that if they came back to
me peacefully wanting to accept Islam I
would open the door for them that they
left from meaning Islam right he
says or they would be put in prison
now and
also right two two schools of thought
they believe
that meaning that this person the
apostate this person would be left in
prison and they would constantly be
reminded of coming back to Islam but
they would not be killed now this is a
position taken by ibraim and also sufan
AI now there's more clarification
because in in
the she
says right three people one is the
person who's caught in adultery the
other person is someone who kills
someone else intentionally and the other
person is is someone who's fighting
Allah and his messenger in public in
public meaning that they are rebellious
they're they're holding arms against the
government against the Muslim government
right here you could say Allah and his
messenger now a sh sh actually offers
something here because the person who
leaves Islam he says that this right
here is the specifier of the Hadith
right the Hadith this here it sheds
light on the other Hadith because here
it specifies and it clarifies the Hadith
that says and the person who leaves
Islam while fighting Allah and his
messenger so so now we're talking about
people who are rebellious people who are
out in public people who are making a
name for themselves these are the people
that Islam has a problem with people are
uh spreading corruption uh treachery who
are who are treacherous this is
considered treachery yep you're going
you're going against the government now
if you if you leave Islam and you
apostate and you want to keep it between
you yourself in your own four walls we
don't have the Inquisition we don't have
a a police that's going to come to your
house and double check to make sure are
you praying or not there's Inquisition
no there's no such thing as in Islam
right the Muslim government is not going
to come and make sure are you praying or
not that's between you and Allah now if
you come out in public and you want to
publicize this then that becomes a
problem right because now you're in the
public sphere now you are what you're
doing is you're in you're you're
influencing negatively other people
right and as brother Daniel and even
brother uh jakeob mentioned in in in in
their uh podcast is that what they've
done what they've done is they clearly
show that this is in the Old Testament
so you know this reminds me of the verse
in Matthew where it says how can you go
to your neighbor wanting to pull the
speck out of their eye while you have a
log in yours MH right so I mean there
are many ways Jake pointed that out
really clearly yes yeah I mean it's it's
in it's in it's in your book the law is
there and of course if we're going to
say that Jesus is God then you would
have to concede that that's the all love
and peaceful Jesus who commanded that
command and then how would you equate uh
then also Daniel made it clear that this
is something in the canon law like
people some even Christians understand
canon law what is that how would you
equate that with with uh Islamic um in
Islam jurist Prudence like what is when
you say canon law what's that equivalent
to in Islam that's like the FI the canon
law yeah you you yes you reminded me of
something here before for uh you
reminded me and I cannot believe Daniel
not Daniel but uh Robert Spencer or even
the other Rashid Hami would bring this
this up as an objection because when you
look at historically speaking um there
were people who were burnt at the stake
for doing what appeared to be what one
would think to be a noble act so for
example William tindel yeah right here's
a here's a scholar who
translated the Bible from GRE to English
so now the englishspeaking world has
access to this to this Bible right this
person was
burnt for that he was accused of what he
was accused of apostasy and or heresy he
was burned another person they had so
much hate and resentful towards him John
whitecliffe because of certain heresies
that he uttered or came uh uh was kind
of claiming out there after being Subhan
Allah keep this in mind after being
buried for four decades for 40 years
they decided to exume and take out his
body and have him burnt to allow his
Ashes to be thrown away I mean this much
resentful and this this wasn't like
couple one off or two this happened for
hundreds of years didn't this happened
for quite a while yeah the church was I
don't want to say notorious I want to be
fair we have to be fair right I don't
want to say the church the church was
Notorious but it it definitely wasn't a
one Oddball exceptional so can you like
if you equate that with Islam like do we
have years of people going out like the
where they're checking you and then if
you didn't you know go ahead and profess
um to be of certain this faith that they
would kill you like did you go did they
the Muslims go around checking people's
hearts or checking their IM or checking
their faith or do we have like you know
documented where you have thousands of
people now dying because no they were
aposta or what something similar to the
witch burning or no no in Islam there's
alhamdulillah there's no such thing in
Islam yeah that if it's between you and
Allah then that remains between you and
Allah subhanahu wa tala now when you
bring it out to the public sphere that
becomes a problem and a lot of people
don't seem to really understand this is
that when you're in the public Arena
when you're in the public space and
someone calls you out on something you
cannot say who are you to judge but do
we have a lot of cases of these do we
have islamically a lot of C just like
the utation of the hand uh or this you
know the stoning that they bring up you
cannot even find like you know some you
have very very small percentage like
during not even a percentage it doesn't
even hit this during the lifetime of the
Prophet sallallah alai wasallam there
was no he there was no apostasy law yeah
from my understanding even when the
prophet himself right there are other
laws that were carried out for other
reasons right but someone simply leaving
Islam No like we have the the the story
of abdah he left Islam but then came
back who granted him Asylum but the
prophet Sall Ali wasallam didn't demand
for him to be killed but I think one
thing a distinction and I think the
barrier or the marker here the
differentiating marker is is this person
being a rabble Rouser out in public or
not if you're keeping it between you
yourself and your own four walls as is
the case with other sins do you now if
you're bringing it out in public then
that becomes a different story if you
don't mind but you know what's funny is
that Rashid H comes full force him and
his buddy Robert Spencer they come full
force thinking they're really on to
something big like they've hit the
jackpot right have you ever heard of uh
uh sister batul uh Hadad batul Hadad was
a Christian woman who accepted Islam
from Jordan in 2014 if you do just a
Google research about what happened to
this woman may Allah subhanahu wa tala
accept her as a martyr her bones were
broken by her own family members wow her
own family members and then her head was
crushed and I'm not trying to be
cinematic here W Allah is my witness
this is not what I'm here for her head
was crushed by a rock why because she
left Christianity and embraced Islam so
people are applying this now of course
we Muslims wouldn't do that you had this
recent in incident with the um Egyptian
lady she came out and she was smiling
and she testified there's nothing worthy
of worship so the creator of heavens and
earth Allah and Muhammad is the final
messenger this is the shahada she came
out
[Music]
m
and she was actually she put on The Mod
dress the hijab and then she got
kidnapped by the church and the church
came kidnapped her this is in Egypt yeah
and then they took her back and did what
they did to like bring her back and
she's like you know Glo me she's not
even looking up and I wonder what even
happened what happened to her what's
going on with her now and this is not
oneof this these are that are happening
but you don't have major press covering
this imagine if this was like a mus
someone happened this was a Muslim who
did that right now it'll be all over the
news Fox News MSNBC um I mean you name
it it will be out there here here's I
think this a lot of people might not be
able to relate to this like for a lot of
people it's hard for them to kind of
grapple with this idea and I I can
somewhat understand why that is you
remember during covid during Co we had
the pandemic right when that happened
slowly but surely there was a different
narrative that was coming out about the
vaccines right and so what happened
later on is the government started to
clamp down on a lot of these I guess if
you want to call them quote unquote
false narratives about the vaccine and
what the vaccine does and what it
doesn't do right so then you have fact
checks so in other words if you're
posting something that goes against the
dominant narrative what ends up
happening is your post is going to be
cancelled your forgive me your post will
either be deleted your account will be
closed in other words there there's
there's there's going to be consequences
if you're posting something that goes
against the general dominant narrative
what dominant narrative is that is hey
vaccines are are good for you we're
doing this we're mandating these
vaccines because we're looking out for
the best interest of our our citizens
and we want them to be vaccinated
anything other than that is not
tolerated it's no different if if the
government is looking out for the health
of its citizens right and I know some
people might chuckle at that right um
regardless of where you're at on that
discussion or that conversation let's
just assume forgivers for argument sake
that the government is truly looking out
for the best health of its citizens or
its constituents let's assume that okay
Islam here prevents a person who's a
Rabel Rouser who spreading false
information who's Insight in violence in
inight in violence against the
government or who is negatively
influence in other people trying to drag
them from Islam because as Muslims it's
an it's an obvious Giver it's basic is
that the only safe door out of this
world is believing there's no God worthy
of worshiping except Allah and that
Muhammad is his final messenger so if
the government is worried about the
well-being of its citizens here in the
world we say Islam does this censorship
in the public Arena because it is
safeguarding its citizens in the
afterlife from eternal hell so why is it
fair here and people today when this was
happening people were reporting you have
a lot of Health officials who would
report an account right to fact check
why because they don't agree with the
dominant narrative oh this guy has to be
censored so this idea of again this idea
of oh Free Speech there's really no such
thing as absolute free speech and people
can understand like when you talk about
treason and treachery and uh when you
define what is treachery violation of
Faith betrayal of trust treason so
example if somebody is coming out and
maybe you don't agree with everything
the Constitution but now you're coming
and becoming an opponent to the
Constitution and trying to get people to
come and change it and go against it
right what what do you think they're
going to do to you yeah that it's the
same it's the same concept what's going
to happen it's the same concept yeah so
people can kind someone understand I
want to bring out the one main um public
uh speaker a someone who's also been
asked this question get your con get
your uh reaction to it and see uh what
um what's your thoughts on sure sister
you said the Quran says that a person
was born as a Muslim and he changes his
religion he put to death sister I don't
know of any verse in the Quran you point
out in the
Quran there's no such verse in the Quran
talking about that a person who is a
Muslim and then who changes his faith he
should be put to death but there are
certain rulings but if you go back to
the history the the of the Prophet mamad
Sall wasallam we know that when the
prophet went to Madina there was one s
who came and said that when the prophet
said go and kill these cfirs they're
causing problems they are the enemies so
one of the sahabah said that please
forgive my brother and the prophet
didn't kill him and later on that person
accepted Islam so it's not a general
rule that any person who's a Muslim who
becomes a
mad he has to be put to death the ruling
is if a person who is a Muslim who
becomes a mad who changes his faith and
propagates against the religion of Islam
then the penalty is death and this is in
most of the countries for example if in
the country of India there's a citizen
of India who shares the secret Prince of
the Indian army with the Enemy the
Indian law will say he should be put to
death or life imprisonment this is the
same law in America same in UK for
apostasy the same law that is there that
if you sell your some secret of the
country either death penalty or life in
ronment so in Islam it is not a normal
ruling that a person who's a Muslim when
he BEC the non-muslim he put to death
only if he propagates against Islam and
conspire against Islam then is the
ruling uh what do your thought so this
is a mainstream
uh how would you Dr zacher Nik every
Muslim knows him you know Dr zaker Nik
come on what a question who doesn't who
doesn't know him right so him commenting
on that so people can see like okay uh
it's pretty much a straight answer
throughout
I think well it's quite logical it's
really quite logical if you're keeping
to yourself brought that so people can
see like okay it's like you have your
interpretation I have it's pretty much
standard uh response right yeah yeah
yeah anything else you want to no I I
just want I think a lot of people have
this this other idea that they're
pushing is that oh Muslim like my mom's
side of the family my mom's side of the
family is Christian my father's side of
the family is Muslim right um so this
idea that oh Muslims can't be friends
with Christians right we can't be
friends with with with Jews there's a
difference between someone being a
colleague a friend at work someone you
go to school with and someone where
we're talking about taking them as
allies this is this is a there's a huge
distinction between the two this has
nothing to do right with being you know
our religion we have to be nice we have
to be even if we we we differ on the
grounds of Faith like my mom's side of
the family you're telling me that I'm
conspiring to get rid of them why
because they're Christians no I still
have to love them I have to respect them
I have to give them their rights and so
on and so forth right and the prophet
contrary to popular belief by a lot of
these islamophobes Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam was that he
dealt with people differently at times
you'll find he was and this is what
wisdom is by the way the prophet during
his s you'll find there were times when
he when he was passive at times he was
assertive and at times he was aggressive
and each and every man in male figure
and this is kind of my area by the way
this is you as a man this is what you
have to understand there are times in
life that are going to require and
necessitate of you to be passive
sometimes you have to be assertive and
sometimes you have to be aggressive not
because you want to be aggressive but
because the moment dictates that you be
aggressive so there's a place and time
for everything I'm afraid what the daa
of America has done is that we're
starting to be viewed as this pushovers
as these yes men and we just have to
smile when someone hits us and then we
have to say Islam is about peace and
then we give them the other cheek I'm
sorry that is not Islam this is against
human
nature right the prophet there were
certain people he dealt with right but
dependent on how they dealt with him so
I'll just give you an example right he
was invited by a Jewish man the prophet
Alat wasam was invited by a Jewish man
do you know what what he was invited for
he was not invited for this tantalizing
five-star restaurant he was invited
for right
barley bread in like some very old that
it's a dish that is so old its odor can
be smelled so the prophet went and he
accepted the invitation of a Jewish man
he didn't say with all the things that
you Jews have done to me no I won't he
even went to the Jewish woman who ended
up putting Su right uh poison in his
food but she he accepted her invitation
as well right so the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam dealt with people
differently you had the uh example we
spend a lot of time on this we'll get to
the next one in in a minute you had the
procession of the funeral and it was a
Jewish man and the prophet peace be he
stood up didn't he yeah he said this is
a Jewish man his companions were saying
this is pretty much a Jew isn't that a
human soul some of the yeah some of the
companions they were inad from what I
remember and some of the companions
stood up and then some of them were
surprised well why are you standing up
they said there was a a funeral that
passed by the prophet Alat wasam and
then he stood up and when asked he said
they said they said it's Jew it's a
Jewish Soul this the rebuttal was the
answer was is it not a is it not a human
being yes for example he says that it's
permissible to do that honoring not
because you're honoring the Jewish faith
or the Christian faith no it's because
you're honored because Allah
says we have indeed honored the human
adamic being yes not necessarily
specifically Muslims
right we have indeed honored the adamic
human being
and these guys would have you leaving
off like you know Muslims are barbarians
just violent they hate Jews and they
just all about you know sticking one to
you in your back we want the best for
listen we want the best for everyone we
do but don't think that you're going to
don't think that you're going to come at
us sideways and we're going to tell you
here's the other cheek but I do I mean
it's it's uh the truth that if you want
peace you got to have you get the peace
from the owner of Peace the creator of
heavens and earth and doing Islam will
get you that way peace acquired by
submitting your will to the creat of
heavens and earth is this correct yeah
yes indeed okay let's move on he didn't
he said in in the law tooth for tooth
and he said no you turn the other cheek
Jesus stopped the Old Testament they
don't have a new testament in Islam they
have worse than the Old Testament they
have something that uh Muhammad never
corrected so today we have to do Jihad
biggest difference with Christianity
because Jesus came in his stopped the
Old Testament he stopped every he he
didn't Stone the lady who committed
adultery okay so that's the uh the next
out of the VAR of bullets that he's
shooting this is another one yeah you
know it's quite it's quite laughable
honestly and I don't say this to be out
of you know mockery or to be
condescending but it's quite laughable
for someone such as Rashid hamami who
has dedicated his entire life his entire
career all of his time and energy to to
refute in Islam and to to to to uh uh as
you said spit bullets at Islam how he's
not aware of this story being fabricated
he Liv without sins let him cast the
first stone that that was not in the
original of John and that that's why the
brackets are there and it says this is
not found in the oldest or the most
reliable
manuscripts this story of the adulterous
woman is only found in the Gospel of
John right um in Bart ER who I'm sure
you're very uh familiar with people of
course call The Gospel books Matthew
Mark Luke and John well they call them
Matthew Mark Luke and John because we
don't know who wrote these books and
there's no point calling them Sam Fred
Jerry and Harry I mean they're they're
written by people we don't know who they
were written by they are Anonymous you
might not think so because they have the
title The Gospel according to Matthew
whoever put that title on it was an
editor later the followers of Jesus were
Aramaic speaking peasants From Galilee
lower class men who were not educated in
fact Peter and John in Acts chapter 4
vers 13 are literally said to be
illiterate they couldn't read and write
of course not they were fishermen they
didn't go to school the vast majority of
people in the ancient world never
learned to read let alone write and
their native language was Aramaic these
books are written in Greek by Highly
Educated rhetorically trained writers
who are skilled in Greek composition
guide him to Islam by the way I mean um
he here here you have Bart manur who's
arguably the world world's lead an
expert when it comes to biblical textual
criticism he says that this was not
found in the original
manuscripts and it was not put in the
the the the Gospel of John until the
10th Century right and here you have
someone such as uh such as Rashid hamami
saying oh no you know what this put an
end you have centuries of uh uh law
abiding uh Jewish people the Jewish
civilization live in accordance to the
law of God suddenly we're going to put
an end to that because of a fabricated
story in the other story is oh give to
Jesus what belongs to give to Caesar
what belongs to Caesar suddenly these
two passages are going to nullify
centuries of living and upholding God's
law right I I find this to be quite
laughable the other thing too is that
when you try to when you when he says
something about Jesus no longer applying
the law that that is an utter lie that's
a lie that is an utter LIE there's no no
such thing of that in fact each and
every passage when Jesus speaks about
the New Testament in fact when Jesus in
one passage I believe it's in Matthew
when he's asked I'm sorry that's in
Matthew yes I when he's asked about the
Kingdom of Heaven he refers to the law
he refer he says not one jaw should one
not one jaw of that law should be moved
so Jesus often times when he's talking
about the kingdom of heaven or eternal
life he never says don't worry I'm here
to die for your sins he constantly
replies with keeping keep the
Commandments keep the Commandments which
is the same thing as we Muslims so it's
very laughable as to how he would use
this and say that um the law no longer
applies if you want to get a better
understanding uh Edie as to what
happened simply look at where the where
the letter of uh James who's supposed to
be the Lord's brother just look at where
his letter is shoved all the way back in
the New Testament does not does that not
raise many red flags it should but you
know why it's back there because it
Praises keeping the law yes it speaks
about keeping the law and that if you're
that your Deeds if you're just saying it
then it's in vain because what you say
and what you profess and Proclaim it has
to be backed up by your Deeds right and
so for here here's the thing for
thousands of years the Jews have been
living under God's law this is not
Theory this is not a trial period we're
talking about Generations one after the
other grew up believing that the way to
God the way to Eternal uh uh uh to to
Eternal pleasure and Bliss with God Is
by keeping the Commandments now does God
know that the Jews and Christians are
going to fall short yes so believing in
God and and believing that God is a
loving God these are not mutually
exclusive does that make sense so
believing that there's a law that you
have to apply does not negate that God
is a loving God so for example when God
in the Old Testament talks about all of
these Commandments whether it's ston in
the adulterous the adulterer whether
it's um uh the the regardless of whatam
that you have in the Old Testament I got
a question for you the person The God
Who revealed all of those Commandments
was that a loving
God yes it was a loving God right in
other words the response that we get
today is Christians conveniently say oh
that's the Old Testament see they're
they're depicting God like a person who
was in his early teens did some very
silly things and all of a sudden they've
grown up they've made matured they moved
on and they're no longer that person I
got news for you this is not how we deal
with God God is Not Looking Back at the
Old Testament and this some people might
not find this to be appropriate but I'm
going to do it just so it's clarified
better God is not looking at the Old
Testament and saying oh I was awfully
rush back then I was I was awfully rough
back then I was awfully harsh back then
I've changed I guess that way really
doesn't work anymore you can't do that
because when we're talking about God's
love and this gets to be a little bit
intricate when we're talking about God
being a merciful loving God this is this
is God's attribute and God's attributes
are
Eternal so it it's beyond me as to how
Christians have a problem with Allah
being a loving and merciful god and
still having certain penal codes that
are a little bit harsh but they're okay
with God revealing these laws in the Old
Testament yes you can say that's the Old
Testament God but God's nature
fundamental nature which is loving and
and merciful this is a part of who he is
this is not a commandment so if God can
that loveing God if he can reveal those
laws thousands of years ago why are you
looking at Islam in Allah now saying
that oh this is no longer a ling God If
He Did It Before why can't he do it
again so people have to get this idea
out of their mind that God's love in
following the law are mutually exclusive
they're not these two have ran they have
run in parallel in unison in tandem for
thousands of years in the Old Testament
why is it suddenly a surprise and a
shock now mhm does does that make sense
because people will say oh we're under
grace we Muslims believe in the concept
of Grace the prophet Muhammad Alam when
he he was with his companions he says no
one will enter Paradise with his or her
Deeds the companions they said not even
you oh messenger of Allah he said no
only that Allah Embraces me with his
grace so we believe that our Deeds it's
a it's simply a way to show God I tried
I did my best I did what I could but
it's not to say that your Deeds equate
God's blessings because our Deeds
they're finite God's pleasure God's
blessing in The Eternity in in Allah's
company that's infinite it's never
ending one last thing when it comes to
the law please when he says here that
God's law stopped what do you do with
the crime see there are crimes that were
committed during the lifetime of Jesus
there were crimes that were committed
during the Old Testament and God it's
funny because God of the the god of the
Old Testament had wanted to have a say
in each in every aspect of your life how
to deal with your crops how to divorce
how to get married what to do when you
sell what to do when you buy when a
woman is on her menes when when when a
woman is off being ceremonially clean
and so on and so forth so the lord of
the Old Testament is literally identical
to the lord of the New Testament right
so the million-dollar question here is
what you do with those crimes that were
committed during the Old Testament that
still perpetuate with us today how do
you deal with those is this not
Christianity turning its back on God's
Divine Law that should be literally
enveloped in wisdom in Infinite Wisdom
are you guys not turning your backs on
that and saying well we have democracy
now we have a better way of dealing with
these problems MH is this not what
Christianity is doing yes this is the
point that Daniel was making that people
them and others today are not living by
actually the tenants and principles of
Christianity they're more going towards
liberalism and they're getting overcome
by that so this is not you're not coming
at it from a Christian act traditional
sense you're coming at it from Liberal
secularism I just I really urge each and
every Christian to kind of pump their
brakes a bit when they say this yeah oh
we no longer believe in the Old
Testament laws well that that God of the
Old Testament he gave you laws to live
and abide by when you say that we're no
longer going to apply those you say
because what hamim uh forgive me what's
his name uh hamim uh the hate provocator
go yeah the hater Prov provocator when
he says oh that's the Old Testament you
can't just rub it off like that you you
can't just conveniently dismiss that and
throw it in the closet and close door
they throw the Bible under the bus you
cannot do that you have certain crimes
that were committed back then but guess
what they're still being committed today
but back then those Jews dealt with
these crimes according to God's laws
today you're dealing as Christians you
guys are dealing with these same crimes
moral they are or not with a completely
different way MH with a tool of whatever
you want to call it democracy liberalism
you have it I don't think that's
something to be proud of I don't think
that's something that should be
celebrated what I would ask we had a lot
of people from Morocco who were really
questioning they were like what I mean
right now somebody going back to what he
was saying earlier but even this him
just being a fake Christian I believe
he's somebody who if you go back and we
were implore people from Morocco to go
do some investigating to try to find we
like to talk to his father actually you
know he said his father was an Imam and
whatnot and he's bringing all this stuff
up it's the classical story we were born
we were brought up devout Muslims and
suddenly we saw the light and Jesus
spoke to me and now I'm a Christian I
think I think there should be an
investigation to find his family to find
his father I second that I second that
third that and get some people from
Morocco to go ahead and see if they can
talk with his family to really see uh
like they did the W shat and these other
guys to to Really find him out to show
what imposter that he he he is cuz this
guy is really he's spreading a lot of U
hate corruption misinformation he's not
doing the world the good service and as
a as an as an apologist as a pelist it's
it's I'm not going to lie it's somewhat
of a disgrace I mean this is we're not
talking about someone in his early 20s
early teens doing this we're talking
about someone who spent decades doing
this but he's still making very silly
ABC rudimentary uh mistakes when it
comes to to Islam yeah um so let's
continue on he had many wives 11 of them
one of them she was 9 years old he was
53 I am 50 I cannot marry a girl that
has 9 years old you cannot that's abuse
and Muhammad did that we so many let let
me let me finish this he took he raided
a Jewish tribe keep going he sounds
extremely extremely desperate like he's
he's got so much of this this this hate
inside of them inside of him first let
us take this by the way I've done a
video about this uh on my by your
permission um on my channel on my
channel you've covered a lot of these
huh I've covered this subject
specifically on uh and I want people to
know we're just basically touching upon
you know in a short amount of time
touching upon some of these things but
if someone wants to go deeper into these
topics I mean because that's what they
want to do they want to just throw it
out there and they stun you shock you
and then when these things are unpackage
you be like oh okay it's a totally
different perspective now um yeah so I I
I've done an in-depth video about this
um it's uh your Prophet married a
nine-year-old it's ons project t a b s i
r a and then project um you'll find it
on there but let us I I don't know where
to start with this because it could be
it can go in so many dimensions and
different angles there's a lot there's
so many different ways you can approach
this huh yes yes uh one of the things
that when Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam um when he
married first off you have some Muslims
who believe she was nine and you have
some Muslims who take the position that
she was actually 18 and not nine for me
as a Muslim what about Faruk he makes a
good case he's not changing anything but
he talks about that uh there's some
conflict of from her herself it's not in
the Quran it's not in the Hadith again
we're not whitewash anything what it is
it is if it's if it's that it's that
it's no problem
but he talks about and just summarize I
hope I don't chop this up but you can go
watch his video on it and he talks about
how they didn't have calendars at that
time how they didn't have and he doesn't
say she's 18 but he just says look we
don't get this in Quan or from the
prophet we get it from her then uh we
get also from her sister that puts her
death at a later age so he says if she's
9 10 11 you know what I mean it doesn't
affect your faith now it's like if you
at the end if you believe she's it
doesn't have any the yeah that's that's
theological it doesn't have any
theological bearing or any theological
implications for me if she was nine I
I'm I'm still happy being a devout
Muslim if she was 18 I'm still happy
being a devout Muslim but here's one
thing that people have to really really
seriously keep in mind we Muslims when
we speak about the age OFA we are being
descriptive not prescriptive MH we're
not out here cuz people when they talk
about this it's as if you have all these
crazy nutcase fathers who are dying to
marry their daughters at the age of nine
because they want to quote unquote
imitate Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam this is not what we're
doing that's not happening today no no
one is and if if someone came to my if
someone came asking for my daughter
which is funny because my daughter is is
going she literally she'll beat n next
year I'm not going to marry her to
someone even in his early 20s I don't
think no no muslim right now is going to
do that that's what I'm saying so people
are latching on to this as if it's the
Beall and end all it's the jackpot and
oh Islam cannot be true no Islam can be
true not understanding the wisdom behind
certain things doesn't mean it never
happened like when you're at an
intersection in the middle of nowhere in
Rural America and you see a stop sign
you don't say no one must have put this
here no you don't understand the wisdom
as to why it is here in the middle of
nowhere but you believe deep inside that
it was put there by someone mhm but you
don't immediately assume and say oh this
must have just spontaneously landed here
right so that's kind of the same thing
so I want to re reiterate that one more
time when we speak about this we're not
being prescriptive we're just being
descriptive we're just describing a
situation that happened this is
something that happened during the
lifetime of the prophet Alat wasam there
are again there are a lot of variables
to to to consider one of the many things
is that the prophet Alat wasam was
accused of of a lot of things he was
accused of being a liar by his enemies
he was accused of being a soothsayer he
was accused of being a sorcerer he was
accused of a lot of a lot of things
right a lot of horrible things the one
thing he was not accused of is I and I
don't even want to say it out of respect
and reverence for Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam he wasn't
accused of being a a p I'm just going to
say the p word I don't I and some people
might even laugh at this
no I don't even want to yeah you have
Muslims you have some Muslims his
enemies never ever use that against him
no isn't that something that just now
came up in the 21st century even if you
go
back orientalists 100 200 years ago they
weren't even bringing this up right yeah
the first this is a modern day age
argument now yes it it it didn't pop up
until I I it's in my yeah I'd say about
the turn of the 19th century early 19th
century late 19th century forgive me
early 20th century give or it couldn't
come up cuz then you'd have to go ahead
and condemn the founding fathers that
was that was that was quite common to
marry daughters off at a very very early
age so it wasn't even at that time the
islamophobes at that time if they were
they weren't even bringing this up yeah
there were many things that you could
attack and criticize is but you're
talking about his enemies who tried
everything at his time 14400 years ago
to discredit him they never brought this
up they could have used but they never
they accused them of a lot of things
yeah right they accused him of a lot of
things but they did not want to accuse
him of how can this man be a prophet
from God as all of you are claiming but
at the same time marry a girl at the age
of nine r r was the sister was the one
of the daughters of prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam she was
married at the age of 10 mhm right I
think I think the problem is this is
that we really some people when they
speak they really give you the
impression that the world started to
exist 50 60 years ago hello please for
the love of God so this is called that
presentism right presentism it by now
the context of today yes if if listen if
average Americans were exed and
resurrected and came back from their
graves a 100 years ago and they saw How
We As Americans were living or are
living today they would all have a heart
attack and be exactly where they're
where they're at right now and I'm not
trying to be satirical or funny but they
would literally have an instantaneous
heart attack and not believe that this
is the America that they once lived
lived in yeah you have the uh just to
push this even further we can go on and
on but I mean there's just so many
points here you can look at the the um
Mary the mother of Jesus the Catholic
encyclopedia has her at 12 doesn't it
yeah yeah and then and and then Joseph
was twice the 90 I think 90 89 years old
so he was Twi double the age of the
Prophet peace be upon him so how do you
how do you Rectify that and then some
even say like but who got her they think
they say God got her pregnant so is God
I mean I mean can you get the point and
some even argue but you get that point
yes yes that God actually at the 12 age
got her pregnant so is God what you're
claiming Prophet Muhammad is is that
sink in people out of your mind and by
the way by the way it was a woman and I
mentioned this in my video it was it was
someone it was someone who came to the
prophet proposing as a suitable
candidate now listen she was already
engaged to be married yes right yes yeah
and someone else he didn't go after
after no the prophet someone else
recommended yes it
was who came and tried to intercede as
a but the prophet also some say that um
that he saw her sallallahu alai wasallam
in a in a dream and he
says he and he he when he would see her
in a dream that he was married to her he
would say that if this is from Allah
then it will definitely transpire yeah
and then you have um the what she
actually went on to okay so we know that
she was engaged already
that was the norm the culture of the
time it was something if you go back
even in this country you had Delaware I
believe it was seven Massachusetts 10
when you break down and you look at the
the age of marriage here in the United
States that's why I said if you seven
you have some nine some as n 10 and then
if you don't even want to go that far
back and this was on the laws and it's
still on some of the laws till today if
you want to go just a little bit back
you got sweet 16 you heard of the sweet
16 why did they say sweet 16 she's she
supposed to be ready for marriage I
think in the Latino culture sweet
15 oh okay so and that's that's just
what is that that's maybe like few years
back 10 a de not even a decade yeah
because they were thinking okay now
she's at this age she's mared she's
marriage age right but if the more
further you go back you got Kings and
and and queens and you have Catholic the
church and everybody they were actually
it was in line at that age puberty at
puberty and this is what it is Islamic
what is it it's maturity and puberty
yeah this is the The Guiding uh light on
this that's the factor because a lot of
people they you know what's funny is as
um here's how far we've gotten with this
is that people when they look at the age
of 18 people have to keep in mind that
18 is not a biblically inspired number
mhm there in Judaism Christianity in
Islam it's maturity puberty that is the
bench marker for getting married so
people have to stop idolizing this 18 as
cuz some people when when it's a
relationship yes it's the law but
someone coming from a faith background
I'm not sure why you would look at that
18 as a sacred number and say oh my God
that's something that they put in place
right legislators put in place believing
that that's the ideal age but it's not a
you know and again the world did not
come into existence 50 60 years ago
there are different cultures there are
different Norms there are different the
world operates quite differently from
culture to culture I've given this
example before and if you look at in the
history you had generals often you think
of a general today what's the average
age of a general today you would never
think that a general would be like 17 18
19 years old not at all but we have
Generals in Islamic hisory at that age
right Muhammed fatti what was he like 20
give a take yes around 20 years old 21
something like that during the time of
the Prophet us b z how old was he 18 I
think he was 18 old can he was in lead
in the he was leading Army you got 17 18
years old they're in the basement
playing Xbox it's all relative right
it's relative they can't you got women
can't cook an egg you know what I mean
can't boil an egg right but so the
maturity levels you cannot judge it with
the context of today with if a uh if
you're taking it back to that time it's
totally different times it's different
and I like what you said nobody's trying
to marry their daughter off at this yeah
I mean we have to stop making it sound
as if you have these Muslims all around
the world dying to marry their daughters
off at the age of nine it's not
happening yeah and understandably so
times are different
wow so uh but at the end of the day
though let us keep in mind it is a
marriage here's the funny never had a
girlfriend here's the funny thing here's
the here let me say this for a minute
because I think this really has to be
said yes today People Are People of of
varing different Faith backgrounds know
that fornication is an Abomination
fornication living having an intimacy
with a different person prior to
marriage outside the scope of marriage
or the union of marriage is considered
an egregious sin in the sight of God
okay you have some people who are living
in sin happily they're actually unaware
that they're even committing an
atrocious sin of this caliber but then
we'll look at the the the life of the
Prophet Alat or perhaps even look at
this marriage in complete dismay oh my
God he married um yeah the key word is
married they are married it's not a mar
a marriage that you you're you're
involved in it's not something that
you're used to and hey guess what it's
not something we're we contemporary
Muslims are used to either but I'm not
going to deny it but the thing is just
look at how influenced we are by our how
we're shaped by our cultural norms is
that you have people today who are
living out of wedlock boyfriend and
girlfriend that's like the cultural norm
today but they still you know they
preach God and I know I'm I'm going to
be accused of being judgmental here but
this is normal for you but then you're
going to look at the marriage of prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
really find a problem with
that I'm not sure that really I mean you
have you have when just an elementary
schools like right now you just see
what's happening it's really a shame
it's really um it's something that's sad
really sad six I mean what what the
average uh uh sixth graders is what is
that 10 what's the average age for for a
six gr 10 10 11 right 10 11 years old
they're they're promiscuous they're
having boyfriends they're having s you
know and a lot of the parents are
accepting this as boyfriend girlfriend
they're letting John come over hang out
you know or letting their girl s go to
Bob and Bill hanging out with the boys
in the basement and stuff what do you
think is happening that's what happens
this is exactly what happened and I
think we Muslims have to learn we do not
and I don't say this to be arrogant we
Muslims have to learn from the mistakes
of
Christians that when you stop applying
and holding sacred what ought to be
sacred then you start having these
problems cuz then when you have these
relationships outside of marriage you
get what you get the boyfriend
girlfriend and then what then you have
women having children outside of wedlock
and then uh intimacy becomes very cheap
for intimacy becomes very very cheap and
now you have men don't want to partake
in any responsibility because they know
they can get intimacy extreme not cheap
for free so there's no there's no
incentive to be in a marriage there's no
incentive and this is why this whole
idea of although I don't want to drag
feminism in here but this idea of you do
you and you do what a man does well
that's going to come with
that's going to come with it's going to
backfire and it's g i think it's going
to Avalanche into something a lot more
Sinister her father was the best friend
the prophet Muhammad peace and blessings
be upon him so today you who who ask the
father where's the father this whole
thing you know what I mean I mean he's
okay with it but you're not you come 15
centuries later you have a problem with
it but her father wasn't yeah I think
it's time yeah I think we can move on
last thing I want to touch upon cuz we
got a lot more to cover and the point
who she went on to become I mean you've
had people who accepted Islam uh they
had this wrapped around their mind they
couldn't figure it out they went and
studied her life they saw her being one
of the great the greatest Scholars of
Islam they saw because if someone's
oppressed if somebody's you know how
they have this image in their mind you
know what I mean at the end the man dies
they writing books against him none of
his wives it's hard enough to satisfy
one to satisfy all his wives none of
them came out to speak negatively about
him and the love when he was mentioned
when they asked when they would come to
find out and study you know behind the
veil they would come and to learn from
her they say tell us something about him
that he good the great she started
tearing she would start crying not a je
tears of like resentment tears of like I
miss you I love you you know what I mean
it's just and then people would go women
they'd go study her life they'd come
accept Islam and then have a child and
name her daughter after AA she was she
had a school she had y there are books
about there
about the Juris Prudence of like
her
it had to do with her so she was a
school of thought in her own and as you
said male Scholars and guess what and
that that's another thing too I think
that's worthwhile mentioning is that she
was young so she was able to take in the
wisdom a lot of that knowledge had she
been in her 40s and 50s with respect to
40-Year-Old women and 50-year-old women
we're not bashing them but when she's
young she had this tic memory and she
was she was ready to take all that
knowledge in isn't this one of now the
wisdoms we see the scholars talk about
one of the wisdoms yes of her also
marrying the prophet because now now she
went on to live and she went on to
narrate her her intimate detail with him
you know how he how he was in Every
Which Way facet of life and the majority
the majority of the Hadith that come to
us from his household like the very
personal matters that that that happened
between a wife and and and and her her
husband or between a couple this is all
being brought to us
via the overwhelming majority of a
Hadith that we have
from is
from not other mothers of Believers wow
I mean this is deep this is really deep
and profound and and this is why some
are convinced that this is that that the
the dream that he saw it was actually it
was a dream it was a foretelling of him
to be married
to okay let's as it is in Let's uh
continue on a Jewish tribe he killed the
whole family of a newly bride called
and he took her as a wife the same time
he was returning to Medina would you put
that as a role model for me today in the
21st century okay I I see I'll let you
go from here but there's actually a
prophecy in this story in the with the
wife of pro of Sophia but go ahead take
it away and we can get into that
prophecy that he obviously didn't
mention because he's coming at a twisted
angle well well that's the thing too I
mean he just here's the thing if there's
one thing that people can take from this
is is this and I think it's really
important right um there's a saying that
says a text without a context is a
pretext for a proof text I know that
sounds very confusing right a text
without a context is a pretext for
Approved text meaning that it's a
pretext for
decontextualization for for basically
making the text out as you want it to be
right the story of
sa is that when
was done in happened right
after now we're getting context yes
which obviously none of them are giving
well he scholarly references context I
don't think he knows what that is yeah
that's the problem um so
saf before even the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam came to Medina her own
father and her her uncle y they went out
when the prophet first came to Medina
they both went out to verify if this is
he the prophet they're waiting for or
not I want people to pay attent this is
really deep now because why are they
there in this area that's another thing
before we get there they're there what
anticipating what a prophet right I one
would think yes they're there and now
they're going out because they know the
signs they know but out of all the
places in the world that that is another
million dollar question but this is in
the Bible also Becca Mecca it's there
everything is there it's in the Bible
the mounts of it's there in the Bible
right is this coincidence no it's right
there in front of you go ahead um so
they they they they went out and they
far they they did see that okay this is
the long awaited Prophet that they're
waiting for and by the way even though
we're kind of going down a different
avenue here there is a a text of this
similarity or of this sword that's found
in the New Testament when the rabbis
were asking are you John the Baptist
they said no they said are you the
Messiah they said no they said are you
that that Prophet that Prophet so the
first that's actually I want to plug
once you said that Dr Lawrence Brown he
actually U mentions this in his book uh
goded he talks about that argument this
is a this is a Christian atheist he went
to Christianity came to Islam accepted I
just happen to have his book here good
friend of mine exactly that uh verse
that situation he brings up uh quite
often very powerful is it is it like you
said I think two things here to mention
is it just really mere coincidence that
out of all the places in the world they
come to y yeah they come to Medina they
migrate to Medina from where Allah knows
best uh the second thing is as you
mentioned earlier is that um this this
is known so the Jews first century
Palestinian Jews were still waiting for
another Messiah they were waiting for
that prophet and that Prophet is Prophet
Muhammad sallallah wasallam so when
Prophet Alat after his Advent to Mecca
when he migrated to Mecca after being
persecuted out of his own home in Mecca
he goes to Medina when he gets to Medina
Y and then her the the father of safia
hu they both go to verify is this the
long awaited Prophet we're anticipating
or not when they saw him and they knew
that this was he they came back in utter
disappointment now you would think why
if that's the one why that's the golden
question why why because Thea
prophethood was taken from the Jews
Bingo and given to the Arabs wow so the
arrogance kicks in he's not one of us
right
in in in in Sophia he's not our skin
tone our color our people from our tribe
right see that's that racism now huh and
that yeah and that's this is one of this
is I think although we can kind of take
this in many other directions is that
the truth it can come from where you
expect it the least wow sometimes your
own hostile enemy can tell you something
that's truthful you don't disregard it
simply because they're your enemy go
back so people they don't miss this
point they went to go see if this was
the messenger they had the whatever they
had remnants of of the Torah they look
in okay this is if this is the
description they come back she's
listening to this right she's listening
to this conversation and the uncle says
to him is this the one he confirms this
is the one yeah and then he confirmed
Prophet Muhammad is the messenger that
they're waiting to come yes and and
we're getting this from her is this
correct she's she's narrating this yeah
it's mind-blowing I agree it's mind this
is like an Iman boost like when you hear
this it's amazing it sounds very
different than what Rashid says right
yeah he he's he's I'm not going he's a
good actor though I will give him a
five-star review for his acting skills
he's very animated he's ready to start
weeping yes right so continue on with
story so saf she says that usually when
my uncle sees me he's just excited
elated to pick me up and play with me
she said this time around was very very
different very unusual is that when they
came
back right they were very tired they
were distraught they were done right and
then she overhears one speaking to the
other well he's he right he says yes he
says well what do you find in your heart
he
says the
enmity is the only thing I have left for
him wow yeah in another narration
actually by the way she she sees a
vision she sees a vision she has a dream
right in one of the narration sa has a
dream and what she sees in this dream is
the the the Lon I want to say it in
French I don't know why the moon fallen
in her lap now she goes later on and she
says this and she repeats it to her the
husband that she had at the time she
says I see the moon fallen in my lap so
he automatic automatically slaps her
right center dead in the face beat her
up pretty bad cuz she she still had that
bruise later
yes and she says and then you know he
basically he translate he interprets the
dream into the prophet alai wasam as
this the moon here is basically the
leader of of Medina the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam so it was
just a matter of time right and again I
listen get that's the prophecy right
there that I was talking about so in
this dream she didn't know what it was
she didn't know what this meant so she
went to her husband he actually
interpreted a dream that the moon that's
resembled the prophet it's going to what
what's the area that they were in uh um
the area that they were in that it was
going to uh come over this area that
that was the Conquering of the
area and then she would be she would
come she would be marrying him he said
what do you want with this uh the king
of the Arabs or whatnot and he ends up
beating her up right and so this is the
prophecy being fulfilled this is amazing
yeah yeah firsthand yeah firsthand
narrated from her he skipped all this
conveniently conveniently yeah so we can
see there's a big lesson here you see
like you were saying when you when you
take the text out of context you don't
put it in its proper uh and that again
coming from it's it's beyond me as to
why he will see I am very I very
disappointed because you listen we can
we can differ but we can still have some
Integrity yeah but it's hard it's hard
to really it's hard to have a a a a
fruitful conversation with with someone
who lacks just the basic decent just a a
Medicom of of of uh Integrity someone
such as Rashid so what happens after
this now so he confir they confirm that
he is the messenger they're going to go
ahead and beat he says's he's going to
be uh an enemy of mine till the death
because he's not he's not one of us now
he's he's not uh someone from their
descendants right so what happens from
there so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam fast forward in fast forward
to right where the Prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam later on ends up
marrying but before that before that so
he marries her but before that didn't he
try to assassinate the prophet sallam
didn't he tried to kill him he became an
enemy of state did we cover
that that that was the thing though all
all all of them um the first tribe was
then after that and then he's from bad
this one yes yes yes but that's the
thing
though the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam did not by the way he did not
kill them he did not kill exil he exiled
them to H and many of them that's the
play
so the people yes that's why you
say right um yes they were they were
taken and that's exactly what happened
okay he showed Mercy in this case also
he let them go actually according to the
C the time the laws this man he went and
tried to assassinate the prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon so
he ended up he exiled him and then he
went and tried to tried to wage a world
what we say like a world war with all
the tribes and everyone to go ahead and
annihilate Islam annihilate the prophet
Muhammad cuz that's what he's say Hees
execute at the end then he was they are
going to keep trying bring the Old
Testament name one person that Jesus
killed because he was an apostate Judas
he he he gave him to the Jews and he
never ordered his disciple his disciples
to he mentions Jesus peace be upon him
who disclaimer we love as one of the
mightiest Messengers and his blessed
mother is a whole chapter named after in
the Quran I think that these are very
important points that our friends out
there need to know uh that we're not the
Antichrist we love Christ and we worship
like Christ we greet like Christ peace
be upon you Salam alikum I go on and on
uh and we we most importantly we have
the same theology as Jesus worshiping
one and only one God right yes uh we
don't worship any prophets or Messengers
we don't worship Jesus but we worship
the god of Jesus and then he talks about
Jesus way never waging a war go ahead
yeah uh I I think the comparison the
comparison is is is this is or you could
even say like the analogy that he's
trying to put forward is is is is really
extremely extremely uh flawed uh the
reason being is that when you're trying
to compare the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam with the small community of
thein or the companions or the disciples
that Jesus upon whom be peace had you
cannot compare you cannot compare the
two because Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam he was the Victor he was
the triumphant at the end of the day
Jesus along with his companions were
not they were not so
Jesus had he been given the opportunity
he would have done so that's what
absolutely that's what Daniel was saying
he didn't have jur addiction now he
didn't have the he didn't he didn't have
the authority they didn't they didn't
end up uh taking um control he didn't
have the not even that he didn't have
the power he wasn't able to he didn't
have he didn't have the the he didn't
it's not about being courageous or being
determined he didn't have the manpower
to do that to Revol I mean here we're
talking about Judea it's a it's a colony
it's a Roman Colony they're colonized
literally right by the Romans right but
but here's the thing though I mean Jesus
upon whom be peace in one of the
narrations he tells his companions to go
sell their money their their their
garments and to go sell their purses if
you will their sacks and to go buy
swords with them to do what
mhm
what are you going to tell me the sword
is a metaphorical Sword and the so and
everything else becomes a metaphor and
everything becomes allegorical no the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam there
were times when he set his foot down and
rightfully so remember what we were
talking about earlier that there's a
time to be compassionate there's a time
to turn the other cheek there's a time
to be dismissive there's a time to be
firm what about Jesus when he's firm in
the new test he says look for those who
dishonor their parents disrespect their
parents put them to death this Jesus
talking about if you you disrespect your
parent Jesus peace be upon him he's
saying put that person to death yeah
that doesn't so if he's saying put that
for your for the parents disrespect
imagine some of these other things like
adultery heresy and all that like he's
going to just be like uh you know Let it
go well here another thing too Jesus
upon whom be peace when he walked up to
the temple and he saw the money lenders
he smashed the table he smashed the he
got angry yeah cuz they were doing RBA
they were doing RBA right in the middle
of the temple now now hear me out I
think this is even for Muslims watching
this because we're we've been
conditioned so much in America between
us Muslims that everything has to be
done with gentleness and love and
kindness and a smile and a pat on the
back and you have to REM we have that we
have that that's we have it there's a
place and time for it but that's not
going to be effective in each and every
Muslim that you're speaking to so for
example we don't get on the mimar and
constantly remind our Muslim brothers
and sisters of Allah's Mercy week in
week out week in and week out there are
some people who are going to listen to
that the more you remind them of Allah's
Mercy the more defiant and rebellious
they become you got talk about the
Hellfire too certain Muslims they have
thick skin you have to remind them of of
Allah's severe wrath and punish them
that awaits them that awaits them if
they do not wake up tie their boots and
they put their belt on and they get
serious so it's a balance it's a it's of
course it's a balance yes and so Jesus
upon whom be peace he doesn't come to
them and say guys did I not tell you
guys to stop this and Pat one on the
back and say hey buddy you should know
better no he got angry he snapped he got
angry but here's the thing too is that
today and Muslims need to listen really
need to hear this is that today when you
get angry for the sake of Allah suddenly
you need to go see a therapist and your
wife is taking you to some therapist
because you got angry one time or you
your voice was loud a little bit right
when it's for the sake of a or if you're
an IM at the Masid and you you know
you're a little bit you're passionate
you get a little bit angry suddenly oh
you're pushing people away from the
Masid you lack wisdom of course yes I'm
getting to that I'm getting to that you
lack wisdom brother you scared people
away from the Masid this is not how you
invite people to Islam and everybody
becomes an expert on how to give dawa
right now here's the thing though when
people do it for social justice causes
they're praised they're celebrated
people are saying we want to hear your
guys's voice even more louder louder so
let me get this straight when we get
angry for the sake of Allah which is by
the way in Islam this is called M this
is good angry it shows your that you
have for the dean it shows your we're
not talking about being loud and
careless here but why is it that when
people get angry for the right reasons
for the sake of Allah Suddenly It's
shunned we Muslims do this between our
we forg this culture but now when people
are out on the street for example and
they parading for their LGBT causes
they're parading for their transgender
causes people are yelling at the top of
their lungs and everybody is celebrating
that everybody is championing that and
they're being celebrated all around why
is that that's a good point that's a
that's a problem this is a deficiency in
our way of dealing with things right so
the
prophet right um theah when they
described how the prophet was he
says
it's as if he was the leader of an army
warning us of someone who's going to
come right and harm us right his his
cheeks or his face would get red and his
voice would become loud the vein would
be popping out yes so people have to
Muslims have to stop with this nonsense
of oh brother no that is the prophetic
way to do it if you're passionate about
something and the community is out of
line and you get passionate and you're
worked up that is an indicator of your
IM now if we're talking one onone that's
a different story yeah I'm I I can't be
hard on you if it's a one-on-one
conversation but if you're speaking to a
community and the community is losing it
and we we're we're we've just gone a
little bit too far then it's understand
it's expected that the Imam is going to
be passionate and is going to maybe you
know be a little bit angry and Express
his frustration there's nothing harmful
in that and we have to stop pushing this
nonsense uh so we got um I think people
can start to realize when you start to
unpackage a lot of this you know sincere
people who are out there watching
doesn't matter Christian Jew whoever
somebody who's a truth Seeker they he
like hold on man this is totally
opposite what I'm getting from this
machine gun method should we go on or we
should start to no I I just want to say
this is why this is why early CHR
Christianity right um I I think it's
really I think and Allah knows best that
for Christians if they really want to
keep marketing that Jesus is the prince
of love and the prince of peace and he
wouldn't hurt a fly and if you hit them
then he's going to give you the other
cheek I think it it is only better for
them to separate him from the Trinity
and separate him from God because if if
if when you're trying to tell me about
Jesus being this way and then I see the
Commandments that he as God commanded in
the Old Testament
it's going to be very hard to reconcile
between the two it's hard to harmonize
the two so just say he's a prophet God
did that in his own wisdom and you can
separate the two that's in other words
it's more coherent I believe as a
strategy moving forward I think most
people don't even read the Bible because
you can play this game that these guys
do and then you lack integrity and you
you lack truthfulness um like they do
but you can bring up versus just I just
do this to strike an example where Jesus
said of my enemies who wish that I not
Reign Over them bring them here and
slave lay them in front of me this is
Jesus saying that right can a context to
that go ahead yeah a lot of people will
argue and this is why I didn't bring
that up is because this is they'll say
that this is a parable that Jesus is
speaking of another king but but we
because I I hope we're We're Men of
Integrity and we're we're we know better
that we're not going to use that as a
we're just going to we're going to meet
them and say you said it's a parable
okay you see how you you I didn't even
know you were going to say that I know
it's a parable you know it's a parable
but now you try to tell some of these
things in context to some of these guys
they're not going to have no integrity
and be like they're going to keep
pushing pushing they like Twisted the
difference between them and us they're
desperate we're not mhm they're
desperate they're desperate we're not
they want they got to sell those books
by by the grace of Allah we're not
desperate yeah if you want to come in
and join Islam if you want to be a
Muslim by all means right but we're not
going to lie and fabricate to bring
people in I don't think these guys the
point is they don't they're not even
trying to have someone become a
Christian or anything these guys don't
even spend any time inviting people to
Christianity what they do they spend
100% of the time you know shooting
bullets at Islam you know trying to
discredit Islam you don't see any of
these islamophobes coming out and
spending the time and talking about the
pillars of their faith you know why the
proof of Christian they don't do any of
that that's the ironic thing I have
people who just criticized Muhammad once
and he ordered his disciples to go and
kill him even lying his name
is he's a Jewish
they killed him they lied to him they
took him and they killed him he he how
does this man say this he knows the
background between you and I he knows
better he knows the context he knows the
background do you hear that you're like
what you know taking imag you don't know
anything about Islam and you hear this
from him you'll be like man for real
these guys Pro Muhammad for real he I
mean oh it's he's basically depicting
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam as someone with this grandiose
you know attitude so full of himself and
he can't take someone criticizing him I
mean for the love of for the love of God
Prophet Muhammad was accused of a lot of
things right so for to come along and
accuse him of something else is that
really
go Subhan Allah um how how can I let's
let's do
this I find it really really low for
someone like this to say him to come out
in public on a podcast uh such as the
one he was on recently to say that
Prophet Muhammad was criticized once
by hello that's not what
happened and again let's provide some
context he was not someone who simply
uttered the wrong word at the wrong time
in the wrong place this man was known to
be a criminal with a laundry list of
crimes that he perpetuated let's let's
let's start down that list first off the
prophet Alat when he came to Medina when
he came to Medina he wanted to unite the
Jews and the Muslims all alike under one
Community not one faith not not like
Interfaith dialogue today we're we're
all the same hey good thank you this is
how we do it no the prophet Alat wasam
when he came to Medina it was it was
tribes it was different tribes this is
an historic document the Declaration
it's called The Declaration of Medina
Declaration of Medina like no other I
mean this is like he's trying to this is
the peace the king of Peace he's trying
to make peace in the community he didn't
come if he was really coming and he
wanted to get rid of the Jews he had the
power in the will to do that he could
have easily said the first thing we got
to do is we got to get rid of these Jews
because we simply don't like them let's
get rid of Ben do that he had the
authority he had the power he could have
done that yes yes he could have but he
didn't because that's not who he is his
his his character by default his
character is loving his character is uh
forgiven his character is is charitable
right uh sallallahu alaihi wasallam so
this is this is who he was by Nature
right it it's when you get someone who's
very loving and caring uh when you rile
them up there comes a point in time
where you can push someone towards a
cliff they can take a step two three
four five backwards the next step if
they take they're going to fall off of
the cliff so there comes a time where
you have to start pushing back right so
the Declaration of Medina is prophet he
comes in he finds all these scattered
tribes four tribes uh three tribes of
Medina and
also the prophet he says this is one
meaning here the word um by the way has
a broader meaning it has eight meanings
in the Quran but the word umah here
meaning that we are one
community that we will fend the enemy
collectively and we will all stand by
side by side as a as one group as one
Community who signed on to this
pack and also all of them agreed to
these terms and conditions that the
prophet Alat wasam stipulated the first
group the first group the Jewish tribe
of was the first one to renig they were
the first one to renig treason now yes
the prophet Alat did not harmed them he
allowed them to leave he exiled them the
same thing goes
with happened after
happened after and
and happened after and happened
after now the prophet he let go he
completely let them go away scot-free
okay so the prophet if he really had a
problem with the Jews per se because I
know what he's getting at and I'm
surprised he didn't say it they're
literally trying to say that that there
was
anti-Semitism going on at during the the
dawn of Islam but you can't you can't
you can't do that because Arabs are yeah
he's lying again liar they're Semitic
people he didn't say that I'm very I'm
very look I'm very um uh I I would think
you know you know not um just myself I'm
not someone to really attack people and
whatnot but when I see someone who's
fake a liar I'm going to call it out and
you know even there's a lot of people
who are out there who might you know be
antagonistic toward Islam could see
maybe there's some you know there the
door is always open but when someone's
just a clear fake and a liar he's this
is what he is you know so I'm just
calling it out um so so let's let's so
go not so we don't lose uh dragon too
much so the story of I mean he narrows
it down as just making one silly comment
and suddenly the prophet Alat is
commanding him to be killed no this
person was under the oath of the Muslim
and he riged he riged on that oath he
riged on that pack that was between his
tribe and the Muslims so the prophet
Sall alai wasam
after after we're not talking about this
not like a car deal like we made a deal
for a car we reig and whatnot this is
like this is the sanctity of Life the
the sacred you know this is the serious
yeah this is serious this is not a
YouTube Share or a comment or a like on
a YouTube no this is far beyond that
right so immediately after the the the
polytheists or the mechans were defeated
in bad this
man right who was known to be a very
wealthy Merchant by the way he was very
wealthy he was very strong he was very
good-look yeah he was he had a lot going
for himself if you want to say that
right he goes from his tribe and he goes
to Mecca what does he do he ends up
speaking ill of the
prophet he I want to say this in
Arabic he used to he used to perform
poetry in the middle of the masses right
speaking ill of the wife of Al abas Al
abas is the prophet's Uncle so he would
speak about her describing her in very
intimate ways but he would also do the
same to the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam those things some Scholars of
the S say those things could be
overlooked but the fact that he was
there in bad supposedly this man now is
supposed to be a Community member of who
of Medina he's under an oath he goes and
he cre creat chaos he's provoking the
meccans to start a new war with Prophet
Muhammad s alaihi wasallam now the
prophet he was not again he was not he
was not a zombie he had eyes out so
people are listening and people are
carrying news back and forth because
this is an Islamic State that's under
threat and every by the way don't don't
come at me with that well why do they
have those every country has Al they're
the verge of an Extinction now yes yes
so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam when he hear this that's when
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
commanded for this man to be put to
death not his tribe him the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam commanded him
to be killed not his tribe not his
people it's it's we have to separate
between the two so this is not some
innocent man one thing I think that's
very important and I think it's the
toping on the cake this man was a very
well-known poetry uh uh at the caliber
of another person by the name of ab now
poets at the time of the prophet or
during first century of the Hijra poets
during I think even of the Jah period
poets were like the propaganda machines
that we have today right the CNN the Fox
News the CBS this and that and the other
right they were the ones who would
caused a lot of this Havoc to happen
they would be the ones instigating the
war they would be the ones provoking the
war and by the way it's funny because
there there's a book it's called Uh the
shaping of the Arabs that was written by
Joel uh car Michael who speaks about
this when she talks about the poets
right she says that they were literally
the ones who were adding fuel to the
fire so this person was not just an
average person see what I don't like is
that the way he depicts this is that
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasam
is sitting with with his companions and
saying who should we get rid of today
who do you guys think of uh let's get
rid
of excuse me that's not how this
happened and I think people have and I
think alhamdulillah a lot of of people
including non-muslims are starting to
see alhamdulillah by this great work
that you yourself you're doing with a
lot of these rebuttals and Muslims have
at least a final chance to answer and
rebut a lot of this nonsense people are
kind of starting to see how much of us a
snake these these characters are are
actually are in fact are yeah and if you
were to take not 10 out of 10 100 out of
100 generals uh some of the most famous
influential leaders of their time uh
people who have the movers and shakers
and whatnot and you would ask them okay
how would would you have dealt with the
situation they wouldn't have dealt with
it any way better than the prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
uh you look at you know people who are
sitting you know at their keyboard and
whatnot and just looking to to to Foster
and promote hate and whatnot they try to
use these things but when when you put
it in context and you see like okay this
person committed treason you had the
other person the Sophia the father
Sophia he actually tried to assassinate
Prophet Muhammad they tried to kill him
imagine someone tried to kill now the
president of the United States and
whatnot where's he going to be what's
going to happen to him we understand
that right in this but imagine at that
time even at that time what were the the
laws the regulations the code this is
all normative this is all normative
protocol this nor that's a a very
important Point normative protocol
that's happening at that time standard
it's nothing new I mean and and it's
according to the book The Laws the Torah
it's according to this that's yeah if
you look at it it's right there yeah
it's treason it's in the Old Testament I
mean it's so there's not much to um even
say more on that it's just very
hypocritical you know it reminds me um I
want to quote uh Thomas carile he said
the lies Western slander which
well-meaning Zeal has heaped around this
man muhammmad
are disgraceful to ourselves only this a
very profound quote by Thomas Carlo uh
and when people really look into Prophet
Muhammad's life they should because
Michael H Hart has him as one of the
most in the number one he puts Prophet
Muhammad number one is the most
influential men in history and what came
to mind is the other side when God
Almighty Allah talks about uh that we I
have not sent Prophet Muhammad
except as a mercy to all mankind and you
had Jews at that time this is a Jew but
what about the other Jews who are people
who are looking at his life uh Abdul
Salam is his name right he was a scholar
the best of the Learned men academics of
that time he accepted Islam why'd he do
that if he was like you know he was
someone who was sincere he was searching
he accepted Islam didn't you have a Jew
also another was it a Jew who came and
put a loan towards he gave Prophet
Muhammad a loan and then he was like
okay let me test him he fits all the
signs but let me test the forbearance
sign because it was in there that he was
forbearing he had to be for you know if
someone knows what forbearance is that's
when you're in this position of
authority now that you can punish but
you forgive and go beyond so this man
gave the loan to Prophet Muhammad peace
and bless you know the story and then he
ends up uh coming back
uh beforehand and says give me the money
you're cheap what's going on you know
you don't pay back whatnot and then om
steps up and he's about to take care of
business and pro prop Muhammad says step
back you know uh give him the
money no he just says that the
person the person who has you know
rights uh had that have to be handed
over to them they have something to say
in other words his his grief is
understood was this a Jew man was this a
person was it je we're talking about the
same story he gave it to them and then
he said he said give him what he what he
needs pay him his debt back and inrease
him and give him more wow and then and
then Omar he said why did you do that he
talked to him he said I wanted I was
testing him I wanted to see and he did
he fit the description of being the
prophet of God look these are the story
this is what we have why are you missing
out all this what about the we can go on
and on I'm sorry I'm getting carried
away but what was it was the man who
also tugged on the prophet Muhammad so
much that he left the
yes is this the same story is this
another one I think it's the same story
same story so this is added in there so
you got in this in this particular case
you have a Jewish scholar accepts Islam
you have this Jewish man also later
accepted Islam you had the uh Christian
uh they
say these were the most learned men my
point here is when someone is sincere
and they're looking at prophet
Muhammad's life from a sincere lens
generally want to know the truth they
don't walk away like these guys walking
away because they're not sincere they're
they're just hate Prov Rock atur and
they're causing it's not in their
interest it's not in their interest to
and and that's the thing it's not in
their interest to portray Islam through
any positive lens it's just not in their
interest no and you have uh again
because we talking about Jewish and like
he said you know he makes it seem like
you know Islam Muslims hate Jews and d
and this and that Islam saved the jury
if you look at Professor who wrote the
JC essay Jewish Professor David War
Warren he's a academic professor of
Jewish studies this is in Jewish
Chronicles quote Islam saved the jury
meaning the Jewish people when they were
persecuted by Christians and others they
were just uh you know ran out of town
Excel Islam saved the Jewish people it
takes discipline and maturity to praise
those you don't like and this is
something I I believe both of these
individuals on that platform lack you
are judging a war that happened 3,000
years ago by the standards of today the
difference between the Old Testament and
Islam We Believe those applied for those
circumstances and stay there they should
not be applied today Islam Jihad should
be applied in the time of Muhammad today
and forever so killing the kids of
polytheist Muhammad answered they are
from them they are just polytheists like
them so it's okay to kill them and let
me tell you about killing kids how you
define kid in the raid of
Ben yeah so again this this the I think
this the last one we'll wrap it up I I I
think one of the I think this he has a
track record for being very guile uh
conniving and and and not a trustworthy
individual honestly because again he he
spews this out like a like a like a
machine gun but doesn't give you the
context he said he doesn't tell you why
it happened it's again he he he depicts
a false narrative that the prophet Al am
was just sitting along with his
companions and they thought you know
what let's go let's go annihilate
B that's how he's making things look
right so again the context is that
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam um some of the would argue the
most difficult period the most
difficult the scariest of all battles
was because was basically it happened
took place during the fifth year of of
the the Hijra
the trench the battle of the trench the
Prophet this was a time where the Arab
tribes Mecca along with other tribes
along with
Ben right Ben was a tribe that colluded
that was under oath right they had a
pack the Muslims had a pact with B right
that they would protect Medina they are
a constit a constituent of this Medina
of this town that what happened later is
they ended up going behind
the back of the Muslims they ended up
colluding with the meccans with the
polytheists along with others right
other conf they call it the Confederates
total in I think up to 10,000
soldiers together right this was a very
very even the would say that it was a
very very difficult time for the Muslims
so the
prophet after the battle and by the way
nothing happened in the Battle it was
Allah subhah wa T in where he says
Allah subhah wa T he sent a whirlwind he
sent you know other things that happened
where the Muslims did not fight did not
end up fighting against the not the the
disbelievers word got back to the
prophet finding out that
b was in fact colluding and was
treacherous treacherous and colluding
with the mechans and fighting against
the Muslims fighting against who their
own community so the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam obviously they're held
accountable for what treason right now
the prophet Alat he's not the one I
think people have to remember this very
important part here the prophet
Alat was not the one who instituted he
was not the one who called out the
verdict they wanted
s to be the one calling out the verdict
because in the J
times were allies with uh mu the the
tribe of O so they thought that s mu was
going to rule in favor of this treachery
let them go have them pay a ransom or
something but he ended up saying that
those combatants again let us Focus here
the combatants those the elderly were
the ones to be put to death not the
women and not the children now one has
to differentiate though at that time
there was no such thing as civilian and
combatant there was no such thing as
you're a civilian you're in the Army
you're a combatant right there was no
such separation at that time
so commanded for all of them to be
killed and to be honest here uh some of
the say that some of the people uh put
the number at 60 all the way up to
900 there's a long a long discussion uh
and the numbers vary from one scholar to
the other in terms of how many men were
actually killed that's what I was going
to ask you next I heard that the sources
for this is a um it the numbers one
scholar was talking about how maybe you
can elaborate on this that it was um a
Jewish reference who's narrating the
amount of people who are there and that
they exaggerated this number that and
you mentioned 60 yeah some people they
put it up to 600 500 but for us for us
it's it's too point it's irrelevant
because the the point the lesson here is
that these people the prophet Alat
please the prophet was not running
around indiscriminately killing random
people if he was truly doing that no one
would side with him his loyal companions
would not live and die for him if he was
out randomly indiscriminately killing
any random person who comes in front of
him so that's one thing to remember is
that the prophet Alat wasam was not the
one who instituted or carried out the
verdict it was sadb mu now the most
interesting part of this whole story and
it was it was ruled according to the
Torah to their own Torah T but the the
toping on the cake again is that neither
one of them said oh this is oppression
this is
Injustice do you know why because they
knew deep inside what was waiting for
them so I'm not sure why he's defending
those who actually admit and acknowledge
their own wrongdoing neither one of them
said you know what this is not right
right that because they know they know
what's what's waiting for them and then
uh it's interesting he he mentioned and
this is from the video before Jesus but
if you look at in one shot Moses who we
love and rever is uh one of the five
Great Messengers when he came back it's
in the Bible and he saw the people
worshiping the Cal in one shot how many
3,000 were killed Allah but yeah they
say around 3,000 according to their
their sources but sure how many people
actually died during the lifespan of
Prophet Muhammad in the wars and
everything some say estimated about
yeah3 14 but what's more important than
that 3,000 in one shot so how if you're
going to if you're going to discredit
Prophet Muhammad what about you know
goes back to the to Moses and you know
the wars that uh things that he was a
part of why I I think I think each and
every Muslim yeah each and every Muslim
should take it upon him or herself and I
think this is really I'd call even
non-muslims for this as well is that
when you look at a battle when you look
at two people fighting are you going to
immediately assume that they're both
transgressors and both need to be pushed
uhh in prison and both of them need to
be you know executed or both of them
need to be incarcerated there's there's
someone who was wrong there's someone
who was right usually right you don't
just look at two and say oh those are
two evil people because you're engaged
in aggressive action it doesn't
necessarily mean that you're an evil
person and as I mentioned earlier
brother Eddie I think we're having this
discussion is that if you have a judge
who who sentences someone to life in
prison or even for someone for the death
executes uh someone to be executed or
someone to be put on the death the
deathbed or on the electrical chair that
same judge will leave that courtroom go
back to his home get in his car have
breakfast with his family the following
day have supper with his family that
that same night he'll go to the grocery
store now when someone carries this out
and instructs for this person to be
incarcerated or to be put on the on the
deathbed does that necessarily make this
judge a bloodthirsty
monster
no it's simply the act of Justice that's
being carried out Justice is being
served right so people I'm not sure why
a lot of people have a hard time
separating the two that okay yes God is
loving God is merciful but we all do
realize that there's still a hell out
there blazing and it it's going to
undoubtedly have inhabitants so just
because there's a hell does that mean
that a loving God can exist no those who
will be in hell will be there justly and
those who will be in heaven will be
there out of God's love benevolence
compassion and mercy I ask Allah that we
are of its inhabitants a mean a mean as
uh we conclude here instructions by
Prophet Muhammad to his army before
engaging in battle this is before any
Geneva Convention or just War Theory or
any of that do not kill any child any
woman or any elderly folk are sick this
is is this correct yeah uh do not
practice treachery or mutilation uh do
not uproot or burn palms or cut down
fruit trees do not Slaughter or animal
except for food do not kill the monks
Minister Min monasteries and not kill
those sitting in places of worship do
not destroy the villages towns do not
spoil the
cultivated Fields Gardens Slaughter the
cattle I mean this is unheard of man
imagine at that time like lawlessness
you know this is like worse than a wild
wow West at that time he's com the
problem is coming with this yeah yeah
come on yeah this is like I mean just
have you think come on how many books
have you read read the Quran yeah and
look at Propet Muhammad's life and when
you look at one of my guests he was
trying to ban Islam uh JM I hate
chopping up people's names but he was a
he was uh a joran vanam you sound
familiar no not at all very nice brother
and he was about to write a book he
wrote a book apostate and he was going
to write a book before that uh about
Islam he's in Norway he was uh he was
looking at the life of prophet Muhammad
he was looking at the Quran his s he was
comparing he's a Christian he's looking
at also the old test he's looking at the
the Bible and he's looking at Moses and
he's comparing the two and he's being
sincere that's the difference between
them and this guy and he was he was an
islamophobe he he didn't like Muslim he
was trying to ban Islam in Norway and
then he concludes he's telling the story
he concludes that hold on he's being uh
truthful he's like no this doesn't make
sense actually if got to be sense
there's more violence here coming from
this direction from the Bible he ends up
accepting Islam he ends up accepting
Islam amazing and now he's calling
people to Islam submission to the
Creator not the creation can I can I
make one more point because I think it
it it might have been a little bit
difficult for people to grasp at uh
earlier when we're talking about God's
attributes we're talking about God's uh
who God is God his attributes he's a
loving merciful god that's who he is
okay God doesn't become come he doesn't
become loving he doesn't become merciful
that's a part of that's who he
is right so people have to acknowledge
that if a again I said this earlier but
I just want to reiterate it because it
it might have flown over the heads of
certain people is that if a loving God
can reveal those 600 odd Commandments in
the Old Testament and some of them are
harsh some of them are difficult to
grasp and so on and so forth what
prevents a loving God from
reintroducing the very same laws later
on in time mhm meaning that if you're
going to look at us Muslims and say your
God can't be a loving God because of the
stoning because of the uh the the
adulterer because of you know
abcxyz the same thing can be said about
you that God of the Old Testament that
was a loving God right so a loving God
can reveal harsh Commandments correct
yes so that same loving God is revealing
right at the time of prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam certain harsh
laws so it's it's not mutually exclusive
one does not negate the other yeah and
if you if you look at it many of these
are deterence I mean the scholars talk
about you know it's very very difficult
to enforce a lot of these things but
they act as a huge deterrent to keep the
criminals in check that's why you can go
to the B you can go to places you know
that are Muslim majority who who are not
implementing everything 100% but what
they are they'll see that I remember B
Phillips sh B Phillips he talks about
when he was U when the golf War was
happening and they had like 3 th000 they
had a dawa Center and the troops
American troops would go there they had
like over 3,000 except Islam and their
stories were like man we'd come here
they'd see everything just left in the
open lunchtime you know nighttime you
know you don't have like a 100 locks
security systems it's like that's what
it is you know when people are criminals
are in check that's when you have peace
in society right otherwise the criminals
are let loose you you're you're being
terrorized by them right you need you
need Law and Order right and this goes
back to what we were talking about
earlier too is that people starting to
see that with all the Looting happening
California this that and they're giving
you know what you know $1,000 you know
people can go ahead and steal and then
and now people are getting fed up
they're like you know seeing what's
happening when you start uh not having
you know this um firm laws firm laws you
have to sometimes you have to yes and
they're respecting Islam for that a lot
of people now when they're looking
they're saying Islam is the last hope
I'm even considering it now the thing
that's the I think that's what I wanted
to that's what we started off with
earlier is that there are a lot of
people out there who are looking and
considering Islam not because it's like
every other Faith or religion out there
no to the contrary they're accepting
Islam and they're considering Islam
because of people who are out there who
are spreading the undiluted truth so
when you as a Muslim you're looking at
another Muslim in criticizing him
thinking that oh he's the worst thing
that happened to dawa do you not realize
how many people are cons consider in
Islam because of the very person that
you have a problem with Different
Strokes for different folks right
there's a niche for the raw Message of
Islam there are people who like that raw
message there are other people who like
that you know Interfaith dialogue and
the soft you know oh Islam is about love
and peace and mercy and we just have to
get along and it's about tolerance and
accepting one another and embracing one
another thank you there's a place and
time for that but when we're talking
about deterrent insurance and uh uh
incentive some people work and they're
moved by an incentive other people the
only thing that will get them to move
stop cease and desist is by having a
deterrent in place yeah and this is what
this is why Islam is such a relevant
religion because it speaks to human
psychology it speaks to the human nature
and it speaks above all to our reality
yes and it's built on something that
makes the most sense of worshiping one
and only one God not his creation and
being morally upright uh I'm getting
nervous now because uh it's about I got
to we got to pray and we've covered so
much and uh I just want to end with this
I think it's very important how how
dangerous these guys and even for them
there's hope if they turn their life
around of they stop you know this
treachery people like this who you know
made a career out of this and I really
felt like when I after because I was
there you know at the p with p and I
want to commend Patrick B David you know
for putting this together may Allah
guide him may Allah guide him he's a
very nice and we had a good you know
conversation and and um when I was
leaving you had this uh Rob I don't know
why they call him Bobby he was there by
himself and I was just try to give him
some doubt try to give him some advice
you know I mean to be sincere and it was
very quick and what I sense was he just
seemed like a very lonely person just
just you know somebody who just you know
he needed friends he needed he just just
just by himself you know you're not
going to live a good life peaceful life
I told him look I said look my advice
for you really is to be sinere with
yourself be sincere with your Creator
and ask your creator for guidance I left
them with that and even for someone like
that is there hope for them if they
change their way and they turn and they
repented to the creator of heavens and
earth that they can go ahead and there's
a there's a hope for everyone I mean yes
indeed indeed there I mean this might
even sound foolish There's Hope for
Robert Spencer there's that's who I was
referring to that's who I had the little
uh I I mean if you look at some I mean
if you look at the life of those who
went before the sahab you look at
consider the past of even Malcolm X it
was not a bright you know on the track
path but hey Allah subhanahu wa taala
guides whom he Wills because what
they're doing is dangerous it's
dangerous for people who are credulous
you know come out there naive and they
look at their work and then they get in
the Andrew brevick of the world they go
and they recommend him in his Manifesto
and they push this you know fear they
create this fear and anxiety Then you
hate Muslims and it leads to violence or
even the Muslim and you give your you
know your day should interpretation your
you know uh Twisted interpretation like
someone would give their KKK
interpretation and now the Muslim out
there he's you know he's also not well
grounded but he maybe he gets his
information his Hadith or his ay from
this Robbie or the Bobby or whoever and
he does something he gets infected with
this extreme radical uh Behavior because
he programmed him like this it's
happened it's yeah it's happened yeah
yeah um how can people connect with you
and learn more um they can look me up on
on social media or on YouTube project uh
t a b s i r a and then the word project
or Usef Susi y o u ssf and then uh Susi
it's not Sushi By the way Susi s o u uh
SSI thank you very much thank you very
much and I want to thank you guys for
tuning in and what most people who I
speak to who spoken to who took it upon
themselves to really want to investigate
they've opened up the Quran for
themselves they studied the prophet
Muhammad's life for themselves and they
connected with Muslims and I'm going to
give you a gift free go to the Deans
show.com and we'll send you out for free
a copy of the translation of the Quran
my gift to you and you can look for
yourself put these verses they bring up
in context look at Prophet Muhammad's
life in context and don't forget to
subscribe if you haven't already so you
can benefit from future upcoming
programs hit that notification Bell
until next time peace be with you
assalam alaykum when they were stabbed
by a man who targeted them because they
were Muslim islamophobia is gaining
ground and with your support we can push
back asalam alikum brothers and sisters
this is your brother Eddie from the dean
show and islamophobia is real and it's
hurting our community innocent lives are
gone and most people are unfamiliar with
Islam's true teachings this guy right
here this guy's trying to build a DA
Center in our country I'm not talking to
you right now you're a c you're trying
to build a dawa centor here with the
grace of God Almighty Allah the Creator
and You by our side we can help change
that at the dean Center we are spreading
and Sharing The Message of Islam
submission to the crater not the
creation combating islamophobia building
community and expanding our media reach
don't just watch from the sidelines be a
part of the change click the link below
donate right now may God Almighty Allah
reward all of you